[Musica]
riuscire a sentire
sentite qualcosa
forse no avete mai ascoltato il rumore
di fondo
è evidente che non si può ascoltare
perché quando ascoltiamo il rumore di
fondo non è più rumore di fondo diventa
quella serie di interferenze e disturbi
di cui però non ci accorgiamo finché
qualcosa a qualcuno non ci dice guarda
che quello è rumore di fondo
sapete chi altri a che fare con il
rumore di fondo gli astrofisici quando
devono osservare e raccogliere i dati
dell'universo dell'osservazione i
telescopi satelliti e hanno capito che
c'è una cosa che si chiama rumore di
fondo l eco del big bang che ha fatto un
discreto casinò e quindi a questo punto
ancora riecheggia e se loro non tolgono
questa tara
non riescono ad avere dei dati lucidi
puri utili e quindi bisogna togliere di
mezzo
noi abbiamo un problema simile a quello
degli astrofisici c'è un problema però
il nostro rumore di fondo a differenza
loro non solo non lo stiamo eliminando
lo nutriamo lo facciamo crescere
continuamente e in questo modo sempre
meno riusciamo ad accorgersi di cosa e
rumore di cose invece ha importanza e
tutto diventa indistinto perché il
rumore di fondo impregna ogni nostra
esperienza scompare
diluendo ogni esperienza che stiamo
facendo
se per gli astrofisici rumore di fondo è
l'eco del big bang per noi è un diverso
tipo di rumore quello con cui abbiamo a
che fare e il rumore dell'informazione
delle storie il rumore di tutto quello
che continuamente lasciamo entrare nella
nostra città della interiore senza
selezionare senza chiederci se ci
interessa veramente
continuamente invasi il rumore accumula
in ogni esperienza e rende ogni
esperienza identica alle altre
e allora il motivo per cui ci scriviamo
43 newsletter senza però leggerne
veramente nessuna che lo facciamo
soltanto per mostrarci informati ci
iscriviamo a26 abbonamenti di riviste
che non
mai e compriamo libri solo per postare
la foto su instagram a chi ha il tempo
di leggerli questi libri e poi spendiamo
una montagna di tempo nei social network
per aggiornarci sulle vite di perfetti
sconosciuti che chiamiamo amici pensate
voi che roba incredibile perdiamo il
giorno per restare aggiornati
e ironico non è vero
in tutto questo c'è un problema il
problema è che in quell aggiornamento
perdiamo ciò che veramente ci compete
che è che la conoscenza di noi stessi i
nostri gusti di come siamo fatti perché
non ci diamo il tempo e lo spazio per
ascoltarci in questo rumore di fondo che
ci pervade di cui siamo scarsamente
consapevoli e allora ci lanciamo in
questo mare di informazioni
entrano in contatto con battaglie
discutendo sullo ci fa sull'inclusione
diritti magari non ci interessano
veramente queste cose oppure spendiamo
interi pomeriggi a guardare se alle tv
di cui non siamo interessati ma solo
perché tutti ne parlano qualche mese fa
c'era una serie tv squid game
sicuramente avrete sentito a tutti
nominare e io devo dire e devo essere
sincero ho visto due puntate e poi ho
detto non fa per me mi sono pure
addormentato guardandolo quindi non mi
ha particolarmente catturato
l'attenzione e quando la gente che mi
segua cominciato a dirmi rig ma perché
non parli di squilli game io ho detto
perché non mi interessa apriti cielo ho
ricevuto messaggi del tipo ma come ti
permetti ma stai scherzando no è un
capolavoro del nostro tempo e di ciò nel
respiro per favore ho avuto perfino dei
colleghi che mi hanno detto ma perché
non è ancora fatto un video su squid
game quando ho detto ma perché non mi
interessa mi ha guardato come se fosse
un alieno
e tutto questo in effetti sta invadendo
c sempre di più smettiamo di fruire di
cose perché ci interessano ma ci
interessiamo perché tutti ne parlano e
il dominio della chiacchiera ma non
possiamo dimenticarci che oltre alle
storie che entrano ci sono anche le
storie che escono da noi e quindi il
tentativo di lanciarci in discussioni in
battaglie che magari non ci interessano
veramente con uno scrupolo scopo
acquietare il silenzio in cui dovremmo
metterci in discussione e proiettare
un'immagine di noi che non corrisponde a
quello che siamo
e che non ci permette di capire quello
che siamo sono per mostrarci diversi da
tutte le cose che altrimenti vedremo
dinner stessi e che dovremmo cambiare
modificare e allora ecco che ci lanciamo
in queste battaglie e parliamo di
inclusività ma poi siamo i primi a dare
voce ai pregiudizi ogni qualvolta
discutiamo con qualcuno
e allora ci lanciamo su instagram a
mettere una foto nera per mostrare il
nostro antirazzismo però non perdiamo
occasione per fare una battuta sul
popolo cinese perché tanto c'è razzismo
e razzismo
a un certo punto decidiamo di spendere
un sacco di ore per discutere con una
persona di quel regista che non ci
interessa ma occupiamo il nostro tempo
in quel modo e tutto è fatto come virtue
signaling cioè mostrarsi virtuosi guarda
io sono così non solo come il mio
eventuale silenzio e l'ascolto di me
stesso mi suggerisce e questo è
drammatico perché ci facciamo occupare
da cose che poi non sono veramente
nostre nel seicento un filosofo dal nome
blaise pascal scrisse alcuni libri che
sembrano rivolti proprio a noi e nei
suoi pensieri libro che vi consiglio di
leggere con tutto il cuore a un certo
punto scrive questo la sola cosa che ci
consola delle nostre miserie è la
distrazione eppure essa è la più grande
delle nostre miserie ciò infatti ci
impedisce principalmente di pensare a
noi stessi e ci trascina
inavvertitamente verso la rovina
mancando ciò saremmo nella noia e questa
noia ci spingerebbe a cercare un più
solido mezzo per uscirne ma la
distrazione ci diverte e ci fa giungere
inconsapevolmente alla morte e non è un
augurio è semplicemente il fatto che
viviamo non intenzionalmente ci lasciamo
trascinare da cose che non ci
interessano ma che sono interessate a
noi che catturano la nostra attenzione
che ci portano in un gorgo da cui poi
impossibile uscire spendiamo montagne di
tempo a fare cose che non sono veramente
nostre vedete io mi sono appassionato
alla filosofia perché non solo per
personaggi come come pascal ma anche
perché la filosofia
porta avanti un tipo di messaggio molto
diverso da quello che è della nostra
epoca il pregiudizio del sii più
informato per capire di più il mondo è
l'esatto opposto
seleziona le informazioni giuste per
capire meglio te stesso e quindi il
mondo e c'è una parola usata da un
filosofo a cui mi sento molto legato
baruch spinosa sempre nel seicento
secolo che ha prodotto delle menti
discretamente intelligenti spinosa usa
il termine di emendazione
emendare che cosa significa emendare
emendare non significa soltanto ripulire
significa ripulendo fare chiarezza e
quindi rinnovare far rinascere
ecco noi abbiamo bisogno di emendazione
perché dobbiamo ri nascere dal rumore in
cui siamo imprigionati a me piace
talmente tanto questa parola che a casa
non ciò l'aspirapolvere
io quello lo chiamo e non da polvere
sulla mia macchina non c'è mica il
tergicristalli com'è che si chiama
emenda cristalli mi sono lasciato un po
prendere la mano scusatemi però la
parola veramente preziosa perché se c'è
un problema che questa epoca ci ha
imposto di affrontare che non stiamo
affrontando è
qualcosa ti sta invadendo e tu non sai
che cos'è in questo modo perdiamo stima
delle nostre intenzioni
diamo l'attenzione a cose che non
meritano l'attenzione è così ci
disperdiamo e non siamo più in contatto
con noi stessi una domanda che facciamo
molto spesso agli altri e di cosa ti
occupi ma è una domanda assolutamente
stupida perché la domanda vera che
dovremmo fare agli altri ea noi stessi e
da cos'è che ti fai occupare questa è la
domanda che più di tutte e dovremmo
porci perché siamo come siamo come una
mentale e cognitiva città di [ __ ] in
cui a un certo punto arriva un cavallo
fatto di storie bellissime di stimoli di
musiche di cose suadenti e quindi lo
facciamo entrare perché attirato la
nostra attenzione e poi quando è
all'interno
invade con qualcosa che non è nostro e
ci trasforma in cose diverse da quella
che potremmo diventare
il rumore ci domina al punto che noi
diventiamo rumore e ciò che ci spinge
poi a mostrarci virtuosi sui social
network si trasforma in cose poco
interessanti perché siamo soltanto preda
delle finzioni e di nient'altro
vedete da cosa ti fai occupare è una
domanda fondamentale perché accorgersi
del rumore deve permetterci di uscire da
questo status emendare infatti significa
prima di tutto
volersi bene
noi dobbiamo tornare a voler bene alla
nostra attenzione e volendo bene alla
nostra attenzione non più guardare
prestare attenzione alle cose di cui
tutti parlano
ma prestare attenzione a ciò che
veramente muove la nostra vita in quella
direzione
dobbiamo voler bene anche alle nostre
intenzioni sono verso cui voglio andare
è più importante rispetto a ciò che mi
trascina verso di sé
dobbiamo tornare a dare valore al nostro
interesse volere bene il nostro
interesse guardare cose leggere cosa
ascoltare cose perché ci interessa
ascoltarla non perché
siamo interessanti per quella cosa
quindi ci raggiunge ci bombarda noi
dobbiamo smuovere questo meccanismo
perché come detto da pascali questo
meccanismo ci getta in una miseria
ancora più miserabile di quella che ci
spaventa tanto che è stare da soli con
noi stessi
emendare significa togliere di mezzo il
superfluo fermarsi un secondo e stare
nel silenzio che ti permette di capire
un po meglio chi sei e quando sei da
solo con te stesso accade una cosa
incredibile
non puoi mentire a te stesso e sementi
sai che stai mentendo e ti vorrei un po
meno bene davanti allo specchio non
possiamo mentire davanti allo specchio
noi vediamo i nostri limiti
vediamo le cose che ci fanno paura e
vediamo anche e ricordiamo i gesti le
parole che hanno fatto male agli altri
noi che vogliamo essere virtuosi abbiamo
fatto del male agli altri quelli
pregiudizi con i buyers con i
comportamenti con le parole mal poste
siamo così perché siamo limitati e siamo
transitori davanti allo specchio a
differenza che su facebook dove realtà
possiamo convincerci delle fantasie che
vogliamo in un dato momento su facebook
tutti mentono e noi siamo i primi
davanti allo specchio non puoi mentire
ma ti serve in silenzio per fermarti a
dire ma io effettivamente chi è che sono
cosa mi occupa e che direzione voglio
prendere
e allora emendare significa appunto
prendersi dello spazio per ascoltare
emendare significa passare un po meno
tempo sui social network tempo speso
molto spesso ad aggiornarci sulle vite
di perfetti sconosciuti chiamati amici
che però rimarranno sempre sconosciuti
perché mentono esattamente come noi
emendare significa iscriversi non ha 43
ma a 4 newsletter e porsi l'obiettivo di
leggerle approfondire capire usare la
propria intenzione per scavare e non
scavi nella realtà scavi dentro di te
emendare significa guardare qualche cosa
perché mi interessa non perché tutti ne
parlano non perché c'è il
chiacchiericcio e questo significa
riappropriarsi del proprio tempo e di
conseguenza capire un po meglio che tipo
di vita voglio vivere la vita mia con
quella degli altri quella che mi è
entrata attraverso il cavallo della mia
[ __ ] mentale no effettivamente la mia
vita quando lo facciamo accade una cosa
che io trovo spettacolare ci accorgiamo
che c'è molto di più li di quanto ci
aspettavamo nel rumore di fondo che
quando apriamo netflix vediamo una
montagna di roba ecco esplorare questo
aspetto che ci spaventa perché è un
abisso ci dà molto di più
2500 anni fa
eraclito un altro personaggio
discretamente interessante disse che i
confini dell'anima nel tuo andare non
potrei scoprirli neppure se percorrerà
tutte le strade così profonda è
l'espressione che le appartiene
ed è questa la cosa che ci spaventa per
quanto amazon prime abbia tantissime
cose da vedere sarà sempre molto più
limitato rispetto a ciò che vedremo o
quando ci ascolteremo veramente non
finiremo quel esplorazione ma per quanto
ci spaventi quella è l'unica strada per
riuscire a capire chi diavolo siamo e di
conseguenza vivere una vita se non meno
miserabile almeno un po più felice se ci
fermeremo per un secondo
prenderemo un bel respiro e cominceremo
ad ascoltare il silenzio accorgendoci
del rumore di fondo che fino a oggi ci
ha invaso conosceremo veramente ciò che
stiamo vedendo allo specchio e sono
certo che in mezzo a tutti i problemi
che ogni che ognuno di noi tiene dentro
di sé quello che vedremo potrebbe pure
piacerci
[Applauso]
[Musica]